but often this on the show we talked to
you know actually coach about great
actors they've worked with often it's
Meryl but I don't know we've ever had
someone on the show who's worked with
Marlon Brando you you didn't think he'd
show up no no definitely not
I was Gaston they said Marlon Brando's
playing the other guy in it I was like
yeah and he said no really we're gonna
go to the island and get him and he's
coming his island you know I'm on a ship
stateside and we were rehearsing this is
the freshman yes the freshman and we
were rehearsing in the directors hotel
room and Marlon was supposed to show up
he was a little bit late I was again
like oh he's definitely a little more
time passed the doorbell rang
we all crowded around the door director
hope we did and Marlon Brando on his
knees cuz he was sorry he was late when
he was only about four hours late and he
was wearing a tan velour sweat suit a
cowboy hat and some kind of slightly
pink tinted sunglasses but I feel like I
might have imagined that part was this
the part of his career when he'd started
using the earpiece and all those things
he did he was using an earpiece yeah
which is which is actually he was still
fantastically good and rehearsed a lot
too so he worked very hard but he
rehearsed with an earpiece sometimes he
would rehearse without the air piece but
then when we were shooting he would have
an earpiece so that the he could hear
his lines being read to him by his
secretary sometimes someone has to read
the lines because somebody's too far
away Prag just distress is just to
remember though yeah I don't remember
he's Marlon Brando cut the guy
he said he said I don't like to do too
many ticks because I start to learn them
and I'd rather not know them Wow he felt
it was more organic to just have the
words of appear yeah that's right so
there was a woman's are like that yeah
Octus bigstar's forgotten bother
learning lines but it is a great it
seems like an excuse of between takes he
could still talk to his assistant so he
they say cut and he'd say you have to
start speaking before he finishes you
hear pause you say are you talking to me
Marlon you've got a magazine in one hand
and you're not paying attention to the
time I take a letter Nick Mancuso the
money is right that he would that would
happen out of nowhere you know it was a
real conversation yeah
[Music]